milakunis was convinced that she
wouldn't be able to jump from TV to film
after playing Jackie Burkhart on that 70
show believing that she would be typ
cast moving forward resolving to leave
the industry after her contract was up
she briefly attended College while
making the hit series I was very keen on
getting a college degree not for any
reason other than I thought I should or
had to cuz my whole family is college
educated Kunis attended UCLA before
transferring to Loyola marry Mount
although she doesn't recall attending
any classes after transferring the
actress didn't know what she wanted to
study and only took classes that
interested her she ultimately wanted to
continue acting so she discussed it with
her parents and they suggested she drop
out while she decided to pursue acting
at the time she also told Women's Health
that her priority above all else was
living a happy life and as she's gotten
older she's found fulfillment in lots of
things outside of acting